la vendée fait cette semaine le dixième
anniversaire le 15e anniversaire de son
centre hospitalier départemental et
c'est d'ailleurs là le thème principal
de cette chronique du mercredi préparé
et présenté par une gare belle ici sur
ce plateau des oudairies la première
pierre est posée le 6 juillet 1973
l'hôpital ouvrira ses portes quatre
années plus tard samedi le centre
hospitalier départemental de la roche
sur yon fêtera donc son dixième
anniversaire
mais remontons quelques instants dans le
temps c'est par une ordonnance royale du
13 janvier 1819 que le ministère de la
guerre saines au département l'hôpital
de bourbon vendée un site appelé la
commune à cette époque la roche-sur-yon
reste aujourd'hui sinon le l'un des tout
derniers hôpitaux statut départemental
c'est dire les liens historiques et
juridiques établies entre lui et le
conseil général de la vendée depuis 168
ans
c'est vrai c'est une exception en france
elle est due à napoléon
il ne reste de l'époque du premier
consul que ce bâtiment
d'après nos premiers revenant du
l'entrevue de bayonne en 1808 à
traverser notre département qui
l'intrigué au point de vue historique et
est passé à la roche-sur-yon le 8 ou
1808 il a pris la décision de créer à
cette date un hôpital pour y recevoir
ses soldats blessés et dix ans après en
cet hôpital été transférées au
département la ville de la roche-sur-yon
étant à l'époque trop légère
démographiquement parlant pour pouvoir
supporter les frais d'un hôpital
le conseil général va s'employer au fil
des décennies a pallié progressivement
les insuffisances en matière
d'équipement et d'infrastructure avant
d'investir le site des oudairies une
oeuvre qui aura coûté 17 milliards de
francs
nous aidons financièrement beaucoup
moins de 10
2e siècle mais par exemple nous avons
apporté 12 hectares en 1968 pour la
construction de l'hôpital gratuitement
lorsque l'hôpital nous demandent une
garantie d'un emprunt qu'il réalise pour
l'achat d'un matériel moderne était
techniquement sophistiquée nous
accordons les garanties d'emprunt
nous attendons même des subventions 700
mille francs pour le le scanner si je ne
me trompe
voilà notre intervention actuelle en
visant les entrées ont progressé de plus
de 70% le chd regroupe l'ensemble des
disciplines l'ensemble des activités
cela représente 828 le chd c'est aussi
un plateau technique adapté les vendeurs
restent très attachés à leur hôpital
départemental
nous avons mené une politique tout
d'abord une politique de spécialisation
et une politique de sécurité la
politique de spécialisation c'était la
création de services de médecine
spécialisée cardiologie gastro
entérologie rhumatologie et en chirurgie
l'évolution s'est faite également vers
une spécialisation avec l'urologie la
chirurgie vasculaire et la chirurgie
orthopédique nous nous sommes loin de la
chirurgie générale et de la médecine
générale des hôpitaux classique de
l'image de l'hôpital général il ya dix
ans alors est-ce qu'à l'hôpital de la
rochelle souffrent de la présence et du
chu de nantes
je ne pense pas nous travaillons en
complémentarité mais il est certain que
l'hôpital de la roche-sur-yon a une
capacité d'autonomie importante qui lui
permet de rendre service à la population
indienne
parallèlement des travaux de réflexion
prenant appui sur la formation
permanente ont été entrepris par les
différents services soignants du centre
hospitalier
la personnalisation des soins est apparu
comme l'un des soucis majeurs un dossier
de soins était mise en place pour chaque
patient permettant une meilleure
transmission des informations
les équipes se sont aussi plus
responsable il ya une dizaine d'années
de ça quand j'étais à l'école des filles
josette du travail en séries ça dure que
on va entrer dans les chambres des
malades les unes après les autres en
faisait chaque une autre soit donc la
perte la personne soignée
voyez graviter autour d'elle allemand
important de personnes dans un temps
assez bref
alors aujourd'hui depuis ils n'ont
qu'une dizaine d'années ça a beaucoup
changé
sûrement à cause des usagers qui était
mécontent mais aussi à cause du
personnel s'est bien rendu compte il y
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
obama tandis qu'il soignante est-ce que
vous avez l'impression ainsi de mieux
connaître le malheur c'est indéniable ça
permet d'abord d'avoir une vue
d'ensemble de la personne rapidement et
ça permet d'avoir des soins
individualisés samedi donc 10ème
anniversaire du centre hospitalier
départemental de la roche sur yon
plusieurs ateliers de réflexion sont
prévues on évoquera notamment les
différents systèmes hospitaliers de la
communauté économique européenne
on parlera également de l'hôpital de
l'an 2000